trois remarques prêt à porter ah oui
quand m oui non je dis mais je n'y a pas
100 m sentez vous convient pas son nom
mais les mecs ya pas sommeil à 17 93
[Rires]
mais que si on est qu il fallait faire
je vois tu comme tu arrives sur les
connaissances et leurs encore du monde
idéal il avait 5 je monterai pas très
fin et ne vous blessez pas aux [ __ ]
relever le défi attend le butin
poussez-vous oui c'est pas très fort
porté jeudi à doha s'est tous dit oui à
hu est lâchement la soie la toile un
sport l'as pas vu
oui oui bon ça bête mais bon c'est ce
qui va arriver que la banderole la
banderole je dis bravo bord qui suivent
a tout donné mais attention
j'ai voulu refoulé par comprendre la
douche on se rend compte tout de suite
je me suis tapé